. Let's go to Cy from Texas.
From Texas.
You're on the air.
I just had one question, yes, please speak
up so we can hear you.
Sure.
Is this OK?
Yeah, that's better.
Yeah.
So what are your thoughts on, I guess, the
Democrats promising 2000 other checks and
I guess flip flopping to fourteen hundred
checks instead?
Right.
Personally, I would take anything, but I've
seen a lot of, I guess, criticism from mainly
the far left.
So I just I think it's a fair criticism.
So listen, I mean, when when they first started
talking about the one point nine trillion,
you could more plausibly make the argument
that, like, listen, they supported 2000 in
December.
And since people got 600, another fourteen
hundred gets us to the total of 2000, like,
OK, I kind of get that.
But at this point, by the time people get
any money, it'll probably be March.
It'll be almost four months later.
So I believe that it should be 2000 not not
get us to a total of 2000.
I think it should just be 2000.
So I don't like it like you.
I believe that getting 4500 to people is still
so much better than nothing.
And hopefully cases will continue coming down,
the economy will start to recover, etc..
But I don't like it for me.
When they said 2000, the way I understood
it was two thousand more, not fourteen hundred,
to get us to a total of two.
And so I don't, I don't like it one bit.
All right, thank you.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Great to hear from you.
All right,